the jurogan experience
i can accomplish all things getting
drunk without getting drunk if you want
crazy and stupid and out of control all
i have to do is go crazy stupid and out
of control i'm sure i don't need any
impetus i don't need any outside
influences the great apache chief said
god has already given you everything you
need
and i believe that wildness
uninhibitedness absolute gonzo
misbehavior whatever you need to do is
already in here you just need to know
how to unleash it for example recently
they i do all these interviews i have a
new record coming out called detroit
muscle which is i sent you a bunch how
many records have you had
40 million i've sold but i think
20 some
30 albums that's pretty incredible yeah
i started in 67 not when i was 67. 1967.
do you know how many fighters come out
to stranglehold by the way of course i
do well what a lick
yeah please do i mean there's so many
fighters come out to that song because
like for a jujitsu guy military guys
military guys going into battle
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah man
[Applause]
[Music]
look look at this look at this look
at your goosebumps those are real look
at that hair standing up on that it
really is after a thousand years of that
thousand years you still get fired
up what a great lick though it's a great
that all comes from bo diddley
when you first get a guitar when i was
like seven years old of course who
doesn't feel
[Music]
that is such a natural rhythm i just on
the phone with billy gibbons and he said
that a a fetus at conception
if that bow diddly lick is happening
remove his little toes it will dance
so my point is is that this right hand
if i jacked off i'd pull my dick clean
off because this right hand you jack off
with your left hand but no i
i hi never mind i i
i signed so many autographs on all these
hats every day and all these flags and i
play my guitar every day and i started
with the his god bo dilly
[Applause]
you hear all the conch chocolate
well what is
[Music]
[Applause]
and i learned that not just bo diddley
but a guy named jimmy mccarty know
the name
jimmy mccarty 1960
my band the lords opened up for billy
lee and the rivieras martha and the
vandellas and gene pitney who had a hit
song called um town without pity this
history so i opened up i was 12
going on 12 my band the lures opened up
billy in the review 12.
opening up for them yeah i when i was 14
i opened up for the supremes and the
beau brumbles at cobo hall because my
band the lords won the michigan battle
of the bands because we were bad
for white boys i'm telling
you
yes it was awesome so anyhow going back
to bald lake casino
novi michigan walt lake michigan
billy lee the rivieras it was billy
levis destroyed 10 tambourines per song
every song had three forehead vein
popping crescendos johnny bonandrick 15
years old on loved week drums
nobody played bass drums like that and
there's this kid throttling like some
kind of industrial beast and then earl
elliot on a rickenbacker base through a
an ampeg b15
uh joe kubrick on a gibson 335 cherry
through a fender twin amp and this
long-legged on a gibson
birdland
and offender twin reverb
jimmy mccarty and they started a song
called jenny take a ride i was already
into the bow diddly chucka chucka chucka
stuff but when he started jenny take a
ride only i can do this
only i can replicate what jimmy did that
night and it went like this
[Music]
[Applause]
get it
i'll see rider
come on see baby what you have done now
oh i'll see you
soon right up
come on
what you have done now ah you made me
love you
nah i'm not not your fan
[Music]
watch this right hand
where'd i go
get the out of here do you feel
that yes yes what the kind of music
is that that's amazing so i saw this
birdland
nobody played a birdland it's a jazz
guitar it's made for plays things like
[Music]
which is cool
great tone huh right
[Music]
great rich bell kind of tone
but but when jimmy played it that
[Applause]
wow so that imprinted gibson
birdland fender twin gibson bird
language and fender twin right hand bow
diddly on stair holy
so eventually i had to get a gibson
birdland and the way i play comes from
the bo diddley chuck berry and if you
chuck berry
i mean the whole
[Applause]
[Music]
now chuck didn't play it like that
because my right hand was was playing
all the counter rhythms
and so that's where the whole
[Music]
[Applause]
that's grad fever
[Music]
the whole
the new records got a song called
detroit muscle
i don't write songs i ejaculate them i
just pick up my guitar goals
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just made me play so chuck berry bo
diddly little richard
jimmy mccarty the billy lee and the
rivieras by the way changed their name
years later to mitch ryder in the
detroit wheels i talked to mitch on
thanksgiving i still keep in touch with
these guys 60 years later wow so
the new record is the continuation
of you use the word primal primal is my
life whether it's with a sharp stick or
a guitar or
a chainsaw
primal is pure
and i think that field to table is a
return to primal i think you discovering
that you can either go vegan or a hunter
you made the primal decision i think
primal
is the answer to every problem mankind
has subjected themselves to
getting back to tooth fang and claw the
earth accountability your step that the
step that you take
benefit the world
or did it harm the world
both literally and figuratively so
that's how i've conducted my life